[Music]
it was a day for flying the flag
and marching to a new order
despite an approaching typhoon the
authorities were determined to mark the
25th anniversary of hong kong's return
from britain to china with an early
morning flag raising ceremony
president xi jinping didn't attend
but he was present for the inauguration
of hong kong's new chief executive john
lee a former security secretary and
policeman
but it was clear who's in charge here
the assembled dignitaries all had to
undergo hotel quarantine some up to
three days beforehand
in a stern speech president xi told them
the unrest of three years ago couldn't
be repeated
after experiencing the wind and rain
everyone can painfully fear that hong
kong cannot be chaotic again
he also warned that beijing would not
tolerate foreign interference or what he
called traitors meddling in hong kong's
affairs
at the handover 25 years ago promises
were made that hong kong's way of life
its fundamental freedoms would remain
unchanged for 50 years under a formula
known as one country two systems we're
now at the halfway point of the
transition from british to chinese rule
with many critics arguing that some of
those promises have been broken
president xi hailed that arrangement
insisting it's here to stay so
there's no reason to change such a great
system
it must be maintained for a long time
analysts have described she's visit here
as a victory tool now that so many of
his political opponents are in jail or
have fled overseas
not everyone's celebrating though
i hope hong kong people can be
successful in their international line
so that the world will know what's going
on in hong kong
a rare voice of descent
in a city where there are now few
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong